okay it's time for hatred mail this week
if you've never heard of hatred mail
before if it doesn't make sense hatred
mail what on earth is this guy talking
about here's a quick refresher course on
hatred mail because if you aren't
pro-life you deserve the death penalty
Patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom okay so this week's
hatred mail contains three elements very
common - hey treat male but it combines
all three of them number one unhinged
conspiracy theories number two
anti-semitism often directed
specifically at me
and number three race an IQ race and IQ
increasingly an obsession of the hatred
Venn diagram crowd that overlaps with
the alt-right so-called race realists
conservatives etc etc let's get into
this week's episode of hatred mail would
jut our surprise Jew Pakman doesn't like
the truth about race and IQ hmm and Jews
are at the top
why wouldn't he like that hmm maybe
because Jews are why we have these race
differences Jews have bioengineered
themselves into being the smartest and
they made Asians even a little smarter
to make it less obvious don't be tricked
this is actually almost genius in some
sense the argument is that on the basis
of the IQ race hierarchy that race
realists have established where Asians
are the smartest but Ashkenazi Jews are
behind them despite being the smartest
Asians are not the ones who have
bioengineered this race IQ reality the
Jews have done it but it would have been
too obvious if they had made themselves
the smartest so the Jews made the Asians
just slightly smarter to take attention
away which is about as crazy a
conspiracy as I've maybe ever heard on
Hadrian male
make the hatreds cry by signing up for a
membership using the coupon code hey
treat for th a TR IOT 4-0 that'll save
you 40% and many many hey tree 'it's
like this one who wrote in will cry
tears of sadness not tears of joy